Hello, everyone.
My name is Reto Meier, and
welcome to This Week in
Android Development for
February 5, 2013.
It's been a while since the
last This Week in Android
Development.
But just because we haven't been
recording video updates
doesn't mean we haven't been
hard at work creating new
Android developer resources.
So, like the 49ers after
a power blackout, we're
returning stronger than ever.
And there'll be no
holding us back.
Since you last saw us, there's
been two updates to Google
Play services, including the
long-awaited update to
MapView, support for vector
maps, pan and
tilt, and map fragments.
We also launched DevBytes with
the first six episodes of
these five-minute video
tutorials featuring the many
moods of Chet Haas.
You can find them all
at bit.ly/DevBytes.
Android Developers Live was
in hiatus over the holiday
period, but we're back with
Roman, Adam, and Nick kicking
off 2013 with their second
Android Design in Action
Hangout last week.
Ian Ni-Lewis and a lesser
version of Louis Theroux
launched the Pure Android
collection on last Friday's
App Clinic, with apps Tasks and
Pattrn the first inductees
granted admission into
this exclusive club.
In Android Developers Live this
week, Nick, Roman, and
Adam are back for another
Android Design in Action, with
a look at soccer apps and a
deep dive into creating
distinctive launcher icons.
Our European advocates are back
on Wednesday for their
first half-hour Office Hours.
And tune in to ADL+ live from
Sydney, with special focus on
analytics featuring Raj from
the Adwords DevRel team.
Finally on Friday, Ian and a
less talented version of Muse
front man Matthew Bellamy will
host an App Clinic dedicated
to soccer team tracking apps
FotMob, Sporee, and Game Plan.
Are any good enough to
be Pure Android?
Tune in and find out.
If you'd like the opportunity to
get near enough a developer
advocate to smell our passion
for app development, join Dr.
Fibonacci as he presents Storm
live at the London Android
User Group on February 7.
In app releases and updates
this week, we saw a new
release from "USA Today," Steve
Jackson's House of Hell,
an update from clothes store
H&M, and a new tablet app
update for HealthTap.
That's all for This Week
in Android Development.
We look forward to you joining
us for our many
live shows this week.
And remember, a gloomy December
will brighten by May,
and you're on your way.
My name is Reto Meier.
Thanks for watching.